The silent brainstorm.
This one is a great icebreaker for new teams brainstorming together for the first time,...
...as it can be a little bit intimidating sharing your ideas in a new group.
Silent brainstorming gives everybody equal opportunity...
...and a safe space to come up with as many ideas as possible.
Even if some people can come up with ideas faster than others.
Everyone's ideas get the same amount of time to gestate before they are shared...
...while providing a distraction-free environment for the thought process.
So, how does it work?
Gather your team and make sure everyone is brainstorming on...
...and can see the same "How might we" question.
Set a time frame for your session and make sure everyone can see or hear when time's up.
In that time, each team member should come up with as many ideas as possible on their own.
You can each use a different-colored post-it if you like...
...and feel free to mute your team members...
...in case they are less than silent while thinking.
When time's up,...
...you and your teammates should take turns sharing all the ideas you came up with...
...one team member at a time.
If you have similar ideas to someone who's already shared their ideas,...
...you can immediately start clustering those ideas together...
...to see if you can build on each other's ideas.
Once everyone has shared, you can continue to cluster the ideas together,...
...combine ideas or even add new ones if any come to mind.